will this Echo dot work with this smart
light bulb and why is this still a thing
five years ago industry analysts
predicted that the Smart Home Market
would be worth 137 billion by 2023 and
they were wrong by a lot today it's only
worth about 14.5 billion why one big
issue slowing everything down
compatibility big Tech Rivals Amazon
Google and apple have been at odds for
years but it finally started working
together to do something about the
problem their proposed solution is
called matter and I'll explain why it
matters in about three minutes
in 2018 when all these new connected
home gadgets started rolling out more
than one in three people buying into the
category reported issues setting things
up one survey at the time found that 22
percent of people were so unsatisfied
they returned their purchase and two
years later people were still turned off
even when we were stuck at home early in
the pandemic we weren't exactly
clamoring for smart home stuff people
were buying other Tech products and
services just not the gadgets that are
supposed to make our lives at home a
little bit easier Mata was born out of
the zigbee standard which is a long time
base for Smart Home Tech like other
protocols it still let companies create
a wild garden around their products
ultimately matter won over most of the
industry including these Heavy Hitters
and all of these other companies the
world got a glimpse at matter at CES
2022 but the standard just started
rolling out in November it works as a
Common Language so almost any product
you want compared with whichever
ecosystem you prefer so my Apple homepod
should work seamlessly with these
third-party smart plugs it's common for
other standards to require access to the
internet see this light bulb it has to
connect to a hub smart device when you
issue a command it travels from The Hub
to the manufacturer's servers then back
to your compatible devices to turn on
your light matter is different it's a
local standard so the communication
stays within your home network it
happens through Ethernet Wi-Fi and
thread which is an IP based protocol
unless your Hub speak directly to your
devices which is a plus if there's an
internet outage and local communication
lets automation happen more quickly now
matter won't fix everything some
products like your first generation Echo
won't get matter support While others
like this Echo dot will get matter
support through an update sounds great
but will that actually change anything
all the experts I spoke to said yes but
the change will be gradual next year
less than 44 of new gadgets will be
matter compatible and analysts are
cautiously optimistic about the
industry's Outlook in the years to come
they expect billions of matter enabled
gadgets to ship over the next eight
years the company's backing matter are
releasing things slowly with updates to
cover more products over time one reason
for the gradual release is they want to
get it right for their sake and for
hours if nothing else you'll no longer
have to guess or be a tech expert know
which ecosystem your new speaker is
compatible with